que se debe hacer de forma hermosa en lugar de eficiente.
Para mantener nuestra humanidad en la segunda era de las máquinas
es posible que no tengamos otra opción que crear belleza.
La belleza es un concepto difícil de alcanzar.
Para el escritor Stendhal era la promesa de felicidad.
Para mí es un gol de Lionel Messi.
(Risas)
Así que tengan paciencia conmigo
ya que propongo cuatro principios que se consideran muy subjetivos
para poder aplicarlos en construir una hermosa organización.
Primero: hacer lo innecesario.
[Haga lo innecesario]
Hace unos meses, Hamdi Ulukaya,
el CEO y fundador de la empresa de yogur Chobani,
llegó a los titulares al decidir dar acciones a todos sus 2000 empleados.
Algunos lo denominaron truco de relaciones públicas,
otros, un auténtico acto de devolución.
Pero hay algo más sorprendente sobre él.
Llegó completamente de la nada.
No tuvo presión de ningún mercado o de agentes interesados,
y los empleados estaban tan sorprendidos
que rompieron a llorar al enterarse de la noticia.
Acciones como la de Ulukaya son bellas porque nos sorprenden.
Se crean de la nada
porque son completamente innecesarias.
Una vez trabajé en una empresa
resultado de una fusión
de una gran empresa de externalización de TI y una empresita de diseño.
Fusionaron a 9000 ingenieros de software
con 1000 diseñadores.
Y se debían unificar estas culturas inmensamente diferentes
para lanzar una tercera nueva marca.
El nuevo color de la marca iba a ser el naranja.
Y al tramitar el presupuesto para los despliegues,
decidimos en el último minuto
reducir la compra de 10 000 globos de color naranja,
que íbamos a distribuir a todo el personal en todo el mundo.
Estos parecían innecesarios y lindos al final.
No sabía en ese entonces
que nuestra decisión marcó el principio del fin,
que estas dos organizaciones nunca se convertirían en una.
Y, por supuesto, la fusión finalmente fracasó.
¿Era la razón que no hubiera globos naranjas?
No claro que no.
Pero la mentalidad "matar los globos naranjas" impregnó todo lo demás.
Puede que no siempre se dan cuenta, pero cuando se corta lo innecesario,
se corta todo.
Liderar con belleza significa elevarse por encima de lo meramente necesario.
Así que no maten sus globos naranjas.
El segundo principio:
crear intimidad.
[Crear intimidad]
Los estudios muestran que lo que sentimos por nuestro lugar de trabajo
depende mucho de las relaciones con nuestros compañeros de trabajo.
¿Y cuáles son las relaciones que no están en una cadena de microinteracciones?
Hay cientos de estas cada día en nuestras organizaciones
que tienen el potencial para distinguir una buena vida de una preciosa.
El investigador de matrimonios John Gottman dice
que el secreto de una relación sana
no es el gran gesto o la gran promesa,
sino los pequeños momentos de unión.
En otras palabras, la intimidad.
En nuestras organizaciones en red,
se pregona la fuerza de los vínculos débiles
pero subestimamos la fuerza de los fuertes.
Nos olvidamos de las palabras del escritor Richard Bach quien dijo,
"La intimidad,
no la conectividad,
la intimidad es lo contrario de la soledad".
¿Cómo diseñar para la intimidad de la organización?
La organización humanitaria CARE
quiso poner en marcha una campaña sobre la igualdad de género
en pueblos del norte de la India.
Pero rápidamente se dio cuenta
de que primero debía tener esta conversación con su propio personal.
Así que invitó a todos los 36 miembros del equipo y sus asociados
a uno de los templos de Khajuraho,
conocido por sus famosas esculturas eróticas.
Y allí discutieron abiertamente sus relaciones personales,
sus propias experiencias sobre igualdad de género
con compañeros de trabajo y socios.
Fue revelador para los participantes.
Eso no solo permitió que se relacionaran con las comunidades a las que sirven,
sino que también rompió las barreras invisibles
y creó un vínculo duradero entre ellos.
Ni un solo miembro del equipo renunció en los siguientes cuatro años.
Así que esta es la forma de crear intimidad.
Sin máscaras...
o con un montón de máscaras.
(Risas)
Cuando Danone, la compañía de alimentos,
quiso traducir la nueva proclama de la compañía en iniciativas de productos,
se reunió el equipo de gestión.
Y cien empleados de diferentes departamentos,
con diferentes niveles de antigüedad y diferentes regiones
hicieron un retiro de tres días para la estrategia.
Y se pidió a todos que vistieran disfraces durante todo el encuentro:
pelucas, sombreros locos, boas de plumas,
enormes gafas, etc.
Y acabaron con resultados concretos
y llenos de entusiasmo.
Y cuando le pregunté a la mujer que había diseñado esta experiencia
por qué funcionó,
dijo: "Nunca subestime el poder de una peluca ridícula".
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Debido a que las pelucas borran jerarquías,
y la jerarquía mata a la intimidad,
en ambos sentidos,
para el CEO y para los empleados.
Las pelucas nos permiten usar el disfraz de la falsa
para mostrar algo de verdad sobre nosotros mismos.
Y eso no es fácil en nuestras vidas laborales,
porque la relación con nuestras organizaciones
es a menudo como la de un matrimonio que se ha ido separando,
por traiciones y decepciones sufridas,
y ahora se desespera por lograr ser bella una vez más.
Y para cualquiera, el primer paso hacia la belleza implica un riesgo enorme.
El riesgo de ser fea.
[Ser feo]
Muchas organizaciones hoy se interesan en el diseño de bellos lugares de trabajo
que no se parecen a nada a trabajo:
complejos turísticos para vacaciones,
cafeterías, parques infantiles, campus universitarios.
(Risas)
Con base en las promesas de la psicología positiva,
hablamos de juego y ludificación
y una empresa emergente incluso dice cuando alguien está despedido,
que se ha graduado.
(Risas)
Ese tipo de lenguaje bello se queda en la superficie de la piel,
pero el lenguaje feo llega hasta la médula",
como dijo el escritor Dorothy Parker
Ser auténtico es ser feo,
no significa que uno no se pueda divertir o deba ceder a lo vulgar o cínico,
pero sí significa que uno dice la verdad real fea.
Al igual que este fabricante
que quería transformar una de sus unidades de negocio en crisis.
Se identificaron, nombraron y pusieron en grandes paneles todos los temas,
había cientos de ellos,
que se habían convertido en obstáculos para un mejor rendimiento.
Los pusieron en tableros que se trasladaron a una sala
que llamaron "la habitación fea."
Lo feo se visibilizó para que lo vieran todos,
lo que se celebró.
Y la sala fea sirvió como una mezcla de exposición y sala de operaciones,
una biopsia en carne viva para cortar toda la burocracia.
La parte más fea de nuestro cuerpo es nuestro cerebro.
Literal y neurológicamente.
Nuestro cerebro interpreta como feo lo que no es familiar...
el arte moderno, la música atonal,
jazz, quizás,
gafas de realidad virtual,
extraños objetos, sonidos y personas.
Pero todos hemos sido feos alguna vez.
Éramos un bebé de aspecto extraño,
el chico nuevo chico de un edificio, un extranjero.
Y seremos feos de nuevo cuando tengamos sentido de pertenencia.
El Centro para la Política de Belleza,
un colectivo activista en Berlín,
recientemente realizó una intervención artística extrema.
Con el permiso de los familiares,
se exhumaron los cadáveres de refugiados ahogados en las fronteras europeas,
los transportaron por todo Berlín,
y luego los volvieron a enterrar en el corazón de la capital alemana.
La idea era que se les permitiera llegar a su destino deseado,
aunque fuera después de su muerte.
Tales actos de embellecimiento pueden no bonitos,
pero son muy necesarios.
Porque las cosas tienden a ser feas, cuando solo hay un significado,
una verdad, solo respuestas y no preguntas.
Las organizaciones hermosas siguen planteando preguntas.
Siguen siendo incompletas,
que es el cuarto y el último de los principios.
[Permanezca incompleto]
Recientemente estuve en París,
y un amigo mío me llevó a Nuit Debout,
que significa "despierto toda la noche,"
el movimiento de protesta autoorganizada
formado en respuesta a las leyes laborales propuestas en Francia.
Cada noche, cientos se reunieron en la Plaza de la República.
Todas las noches montaron un pequeño pueblo, temporal
para deliberar sobre su propia visión de la República Francesa.
Y en el centro de esta adhocracia
había una asamblea general donde cualquiera podía hablar
utilizando un lenguaje de signos especialmente diseñado.
Al igual que Ocupa Wall Street y otros movimientos de protesta,
Nuit Debout nació en respuesta a la crisis.
Era desordenado,
lleno de controversias y contradicciones.
Pero estuviera uno de acuerdo o no con los objetivos del movimiento,
cada reunión era una hermosa lección de humanidad en bruto.
Y como diseñado a la medida, París,
la ciudad de los ideales, la ciudad de la belleza,
fue su escenario.
Eso nos recuerda que como en grandes ciudades,
las organizaciones más hermosas son las ideas por las que vale la pena luchar,
incluso, y, sobre todo, cuando su resultado es incierto.
Son movimientos;
son siempre imperfectos, nunca se organizan del todo,
por eso no llegan a ser nunca banales.
Ellos tienen algo, pero no saben lo que es.
Siguen siendo un misterio; no podemos apartar la vista de ellos.
Los encontramos hermosos.
Así que hacer lo innecesario,
crear la intimidad,
ser feo,
permanecer incompletos,
no solo son las cualidades de las organizaciones hermosas,
estas son características inherentemente humanas.
Y también las cualidades de lo que llamamos hogar.
Y a medida que se desbaratan y se ven perturbadas,
lo menos que podemos hacer es garantizar
que todavía nos sentimos como en casa en nuestras organizaciones,
y que usamos nuestras organizaciones para crear ese sentido para los otros.
La belleza puede salvar al mundo si abrazamos estos principios
y el diseño para ellos.
A la vista de la inteligencia artificial y el aprendizaje automático,
necesitamos un nuevo humanismo radical.
Debemos adquirir y promover una nueva educación estética y sentimental,
porque si no lo hacemos,
podríamos llegar a sentirnos como extraterrestres
en las organizaciones y sociedades que están llenas de máquinas inteligentes
que no tienen, en absoluto, aprecio
por lo innecesario,
por lo íntimo,
por lo incompleto
y, definitivamente, no por lo feo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)